welcome back everyone okay so in the
last few lectures we've been looking at
balancing transformations so those are
coordinate transformations from some
original x-coordinates into some new z
coordinates so that my controllability
and observability graeme ins in these z
coordinates WC hat equals wo hat equals
a diagonal and hierarchically ordered
matrix sigma ok so my my controllability
graeme an equals my observability grammy
an equals a diagonal matrix where the
entries are going from biggest to
smallest ok so now we're going to code
this up in MATLAB again just as an
illustration this is kind of the end
figure that we're going to generate we
have our observability grammy and for
our original system in blue here so
there's this really observable direction
and this one's not as observable I have
my red controllability Graham Ian so
again this direction is super
controllable this direction is barely
controllable but in these balanced
coordinates that what we're going to do
is we're going to find this T transform
in these new coordinates Z where I find
a hierarchical coordinate system so that
the first coordinate in this purple
direction this kind of Direction here is
the most jointly controllable and
observable direction so this is a
compromise between this granion and this
granion so this direction and it tells
me that if I wanted to truncate if I
only wanted a one mode model I would get
rid of this direction because this is
the least jointly controllable and
observable okay so that's what we're
gonna do in MATLAB is cook up this
balancing transformation and balance
these grand means ok great and you can
do this at home the script is on line
links to all the codes are available
this is also in the book on data driven
science and engineering ok so here's
what we're gonna do we're just going to
cook up a system a two-by-two system
with one input and one output no D
matrix no feed through terms so an a B
and C matrix in MATLAB it's easy to
build a state-space system with the SS
command so we're gonna build a state
space system and I'm going to look at
what the controllability and
observability graeme ins are
using this convenient Graham command
okay so I'm just gonna run all of this
control-enter okay it's running and now
let's just verify that our
controllability and observability Graham
Ian's are not equal
okay so WC is this matrix not diagonal
okay it's not a diagonal matrix first of
all and then remember what it looks like
and then wo is not equal to that in fact
it's almost opposite right like this
direction is more more observable and
this direction was more controllable
okay so these are kind of those those
two ellipsoids now plotting these things
is kind of fun so what I'm gonna do to
plot these Graham Ian's I'm going to
define basically a unit sphere or a
circle in r2 and I'm going to map that
circle through these these
controllability and observability
grampians and remember these Graham
Ian's are positive semi-definite so what
I'm going to do is I'm actually going to
map through the square root of the
Graeme and this is just for scaling okay
and so my circle is going to turn into a
controllability ellipse and an
observability ellipse and I'm then going
to plot those ellipses so that's all I'm
doing here okay I've got my red and blue
a observability and controllability
ellipses so I'm just gonna put this in
the background and go back here now that
was just to get the controllability and
observability in my original x
coordinates but what I want is I want
controllability I want those new
coordinate system Z where these are
balanced and equal so that's what we're
gonna do now okay and I make it look
cool by making my current axes and
current figure color black background
okay so you want to make super cool
black background figures okay so the
great thing about MATLAB is that
computing these balancing
transformations is one line this is
super simple I think one of the great
things about this is that matlab's I
think this is maybe the robust control
toolbox or maybe the original control
toolbox essentially wraps Fortran code I
think written by by Peter better
in in the 80s if I'm not mistaken called
sly khat and essentially it wraps this
super-powerful Fortran code that does
all of this numerical linear algebra
even for pretty large systems so what
we're gonna do is we're going to find a
balanced realization of our system this
is a built in MATLAB command ball rail
Balance realization and when it gives me
is the balanced system and then these
transformations T and the inverse
transformation s is what I called it
before they call it T inverse and I
can't remember what G is but if I was
doing this I give my diagonal elements
of Sigma probably ok and then all I'm
gonna do is I'm going to look at what
the Graeme ins of this balanced system
are because in these balanced
coordinates these Graeme ins should be
equal and diagonal then I'm going to run
my circle through this coordinate system
and I can't just use BWC because I have
to map into those coordinates and out of
those coordinates with T and T inverse
so you can kind of go through the math
and convince yourself that this is
really how to draw these ellipses but
this is that ellipse from before and
then I'm gonna plot it in purple because
it's supposed to be the compromise
between my red and blue controllability
and observability ellipses okay that
makes sense
ok take away one line MATLAB command to
balance the system I run Bal rail on my
system and I get a balanced system and
the direct and inverse transforms and
all of this is just verifying that it
gives me a balanced model okay so let's
run this control enter and a couple
things first of all in my command window
I plotted the controllability the BWC
this is my balanced controllability
granion okay 1.9 four three nine and
0.32 so it's diagonal and now I'm gonna
plot my balanced observability Graham in
and it's the same it's exactly the same
these little minus is popped up because
those are zero plus or minus something
really really small but basically my
balanced controllability and
observability grampians are equal and
diagonal and what's really cool notice
that this first diagonal entry is a lot
bigger than mice
second diagonal entry that means this
one's a lot more important for control
controllability and observability so
this one you know is more than five or
six times more important than this one
so if I wanted to only pick one state I
pick the Z one coordinate and I throw
away the Z two coordinate okay
so then remember I plotted my original
observability and controllability graeme
ins in blue and red now what I'm doing
is I'm plotting in these balance
coordinates so I map into Z coordinates
I plot my ellipse and then I map out to
show it in the x coordinates and I get
this this nice purple ellipsoid which
balances the trade-offs between good
observability and good controllability
okay pretty simple really you can do
this to much larger systems I'm showing
you this on a two-by-two system just so
we can plot everything and see it and
play around with it but you can imagine
that these ellipsoids in three
dimensions might look like an mm or you
know a football or something like that
in ten dimensions they're gonna be this
hyper ellipsoid and in a thousand
dimensions you know everything
generalizes so you still get these
ellipsoids you still get preferred
directions you still get trade-offs
between controllability and
observability so that's all really
really interesting easy to plot even
easier to compute notice that like all
of my commands here are just building
the matrices building the system and
plotting one line for balancing your
system okay and if you're interested I
actually did write a code that allows
you to manually compute these balancing
transformations remember we if you
remember from before what we actually
did was we took the original Graham
Ian's WC x wo times T equals T Sigma
squared and if I remember this was an
unscaled set of eigenvectors t and then
we went through some scaling to find the
scaled coordinate transformation T that
that exactly balances and diagonalizes
these Grammies
and that's what this code here does okay
so I basically take the eigen
decomposition of this product here that
gives me T unscaled and a diagonal
matrix that's Sigma squared and then I
go through all of the business of
building these Graham Ian's and scaling
T and
then you can convince yourself through
the end of this that this tea is the
same as you get with the ball real
commands I'm not going to run it you can
run it all the codes are online now the
upshot of course is just going to run
this again yeah the upshot is one line
MATLAB command I can take a system that
has some preferred observability
directions other preserve preferred
controllability directions and what it
will do is it will automatically just
using linear algebra find a hierarchy of
most to least jointly controllable and
observable notes why is that important
this is important because if I have a
million dimensional system and I want to
control it really fast there's fast
timescales and I have to control it
super fast then I need to approximate
that million dimensional system with the
best possible five or ten or twenty
dimensional system that I can actually
simulate and control online and so what
this does is this gives me a principled
approach to pruning down that very high
dimensional state space X into a
hierarchy of the most to least important
coordinates in Z so I can pick the first
five coordinates of Z the first ten
coordinates of Z and every time I add
more I'm kind of guaranteed to be
capturing the next most controllable and
observable States ok that's it for now
thank you